a two-time Olympic gold medalist Carly
Lloyd she's a soccer player she has just
made a shocking declaration she has
declared that men are better at soccer
than women someone responded to her and
said hey is it true that you guys lost
to a bunch of 15-year-old boys you
sometimes hear this that the women's
soccer team the professional women's
soccer team lost to a group of
15-year-old boys and she she responds
and he goes yeah that's true I know
thousands of people have already brought
that up the boys were good we actually
lost to a youth Bayern Munich team in my
career as well but then we went on to
win the Olympics in the world cup
so yeah we we lost to boys cuz we're
girls but then we beat other girls
because we're relatively better at
soccer than other girls she goes haha
they should beat us they should the boys
should beat us they're bigger stronger
and faster boys always gave us a run for
our money and that was great prep what a
great attitude this woman almost could
get me to like soccer